A few months ahead of presidential elections
in Nigeria, Boko Haram jihadists have killed
dozens of soldiers and civilians in the north
of the country.
President Muhammadu Buhari is under fire for
his failure to defeat the insurgents.
The remains of a village in North-East Nigeria,
just a few kilometers away from the regional
capital Maiduguri.
Jihadists came on motorbikes in broad daylight
– kidnapping 12 farmers and killing nine
who refused to come with them.
They slapped me first and shot my husband
in front of me.
They took my phone, my money, and my shoes.
Then they started beating me and told me to
go home immediately.
The day before that attack, Boko Haram struck
this Nigerian military base close to the border
with Chad.
This video – allegedly filmed by a soldier
– triggered huge discussions on social media
in Nigeria.
Eyewitness say about 100 soldiers were killed
and several abducted.
Some soldiers themselves feel abandoned by
their government.
Imagine, they are killing us every day.
A soldier will be at the war front – no
helmet, no flak jacket, not enough amination.
We are fighting to defend our country – and
the generals are cheating us.
The Nigerian army confirmed that the military
base was attacked – but has refused to comment
on the casualties.
For security expert and retired Colonel Yomi
Dare, the attack is a huge embarrassment for
the armed forces.
For a soldier making such allegations, I think
something is really wrong.
Something is not right somewhere.
I think it is high time that the military
authority puts up a transparent and accountable
system.
So when things that are meant for the troops,
they should ensure that those things really
get there.
And are delivered especially to the front
line.
Nigeria’s president Muhammadu Buhari won
the 2015 elections on the promise of ending
the fight against Boko Haram.
Despite first successes - Dare doesn’t see
a quick end to the crisis.
Getting an insurgency to an end is a tall
order.
Let nobody be deceived.
Unfortunately, people want to play politics
with everything.
I don’t think this is where the politicians
should come and start talking.
Because this is a war – and we should not
toy with it at all.”
More than 20,000 people have been killed since
the Boko Haram insurgency started almost a
decade ago.
With presidential elections scheduled early
next year – Nigerians living in areas still
terrorized by Boko Haram are asking, who will
finally be able to stop these killings?